explique les règles parce qu'on va voir
quelqu'un au téléphone et vous allez
jouer chez vous également que c'est très
surfait choisir car ils vont mettre un
coup de poing nora en plus cédric et moi
d'ailleurs je veux dire que 3 n'aura
cédric heymans
vous mettez un coup de poing si vous
faites entre 0 et 200 vous gagnez 0 coup
de poing ici avec des cadeaux si vous
faites entre 200 et 400 deux coups de
poing si vous faites entre 400 et 600 et
à combien est assis vous faites moins
400 et 600 vous gagnez deux coups de
poing 600 et 700 trois coups de poing au
dessus de 704 coup de poing à chaque
fois il ya des cadeaux il ya des cadeaux
pour y ait des cadeaux très bien vous
prenez le cadeau si vous êtes content
vous le gagnez et téléspectateurs aussi
le ghanéen pas content vous dites je
continue d'accord avec quatre mois
forcément gagné cadiale la paix c'est
sûr ouais tu peux prendre le risque ou
pas non non ça va te sens tu à ton
combat avec toi même pas forte de la
main gauche
exact mais même comme ça tape avec le
droit de dire on va prendre qu'elle y
aller c'est vrai mais délègue et je vous
propose un petit cadeau et des canaux
pour la com com - ouais mais oui mais
oui on a les mains sales et bazana
téléphone allô allô allô allô allô
monsieur l'ordinateur
oui bah 60 ans quitte après on est bien
à lille salue car encore ça va sherry
barrât très bien alors d'où tu nous
appelles world you leave you know what
vie normale vilain pas un lien c'est
noël c'était très fort en basket avant
oui là ils ont un peu ça commence un peu
l'asvel j'adore on n'aura qu'à se mêlent
le basket bim al assad or et et ma
chérie tu fais quoi dans la vie
non c'est pas vrai lit et ben ça va ça
va taper n'a pas reçu ta part sont
recommandés pour kelly
mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait je vais
là-bas je veux jouer mais c'est bon en
plus qu'il s'entraîne mais même pas
passé sinon je reste comme ça et b6
prenez le tri nations
c'est mon rôle à la baisse jean-michel
mais c'est quoi alors les séries à
thierry caroline tu vas jouer avec nous
tu es marié était forcée des pacsés avec
ti ma chérie mon mari jean-luc s'il vous
plaît pas très bien ce n'est pas pour
aujourd'hui
merci allez on va jouer on va te faire
gagner plein de cadeaux machin d'accord
attention c'est parti on va démarrer
avec le premier coup de poing
c'est pas mal
mais pas
magnifique show 95 tu as donc gagné
trois coups de poing donc attention
mettez vous parle avec moi a fait avec
moi c est d aller belgique
voilà voilà vannes est choisi et 3,4
soit 3,4 d'abord vécu 3 pourquoi ces
pourris ouais n'y a rien voilà alors
choisi d'abord dans sa là à commencer
par celle là nous aurons nous c'est pas
terrible savoir c'est quoi à une fausse
moustache
non mais quel est ce que tu continues
continue et chocolat temps caroline tu
t'intéresses la donne la fausse
moustache
je m'en doutais un peu merci papa décédé
bon bah quoi une moustache une nouvelle
moustache tu continues bah oui allez
vas-y continue et un peu plus bas on
amplifie ce type m'a dit j'ai dit à quoi
y'a suppositoire tu gagnes à 6000 à 10
dans ce combat tu peux gagner je suppose
d'en attaquer ni c'est pas mal à gagner
il touche aux nlfa calembours caroli
vas-y et tenait la toiture qu'est ce
qu'elle a gagné à contre téléphone
portable et un téléphone portable pour
carnival a l'air si je vais jouer pour
toi caroline caroline et cédric sérique
ouais je postule best way est sûr que
ces bombes a fait appel de la main
gauche en asie a évalué le de la
magouille basse mais je vais essayer de
voir des gars fort et montrer le talent
technique et vos cadeaux pour kelly
avait fait gaffe any way sympa sa part
quand même si j'ai déjà dit que je ne
voulais pas coché mais quand savais que
ma gauche un peu sous sa moye pour
cédric hengbart a dit série oui toi y'a
quoi que tu aimes ou tu continues à ce
que tu en as déjà donc tu continues à
huy une lime à ongles est-ce que tu
continues ans tu t'arrêtes caroline
continue bribes à oui j'avais beaucoup
et ça c'est pas les cadeaux vas-y tard
et n'ont pas été en reste deux
j'en ai fait je continue ou caro oui
vas-y vas-y select vas-y vas-y
après donc tu donnes pour l'instant une
[ __ ] à mouches ont un téléphone
portable et un suppositoire
je veux jouer est ce qu'on a le temps ce
que j'ai tant de jouer les chirurgies
oui il écoeure 19h24 samossa merci à
lehman a en fait ça sans mon avis bande
mode quand même non mais non ça fera que
4 1 ouais donc ça fera qu'à gaza une
valise est-ce que ça non mais parce
qu'attention est-ce que tu continues ou
est-ce que tu prends la valise et vous
de sciences à bettié continue la compil
de baba a trop laissé ma chérie donc un
booster les boutons de ma gueule alors
tu l'as déjà attention va jouer sur ce
cadeau mathieu aller très important je
le sens là et non la copie de la ba ba
ma chérie donc tu regardes la compil le
ba ba tu gagnes un suppositoire tu
gagnes un téléphone par habitat du gard
matane où ça te bats caron pas un amant
mathieu ou te fait d'énormes bisous aux
thèmes très très très très fort et est
ce que voulait taper vous pour voir pour
le plaisir des fans
mais non mais mollo jamal atteindre
cette femme elle a buggé c'est vrai je
rappelle que tu combats samedi mon chéri
le 10 mars
vas-y gecas avait été non ça va être